so Logan Paul wrong way things are never
thought I'd say on a video
ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding meaning
top answer weird life is so [__]
weird the last week has been the most
mental week of my youtube life hands
[__] down so after last week's
response to log and Paul you long you
meant mendel the support was
un-fuckin'-believable I've never known
anything like I didn't even think people
gave a [__] and as someone who I'm not
gonna get emotional on this video right
there's just there's too much to be
happy for as someone who loves what he
does to know people appreciate what I do
a [__] means the world that was and
like I'm saying [__] petitions going
up on Twitter you know everyone sign I'm
not retweeting these everyone just sign
I think one petition had over like 50
and 60 and thousand signatures just to
get me to commenting on the fight I mean
mind blown only YouTube Bros who came
out and supporters went to bat for us
from boogie2988 Joella all the countries
all the lads I mean you know that really
means a lot when your peers and people
you respect respect you I'm not gonna
cry but it really is it means a [__]
world that was genuinely one youtuber
who deserves a special at the show now
it's got to be Skye Williams his video
on Twitter but I've had me thinking a
lot of things to be honest okay my [__]
look I'm gonna be honest do I know
exactly who you are
no did I follow you because I thirst
absolutely is how you start a video so
what doesn't want you commentating I
have no idea why you would say that but
I'm willing to fight for you he's ready
he's gonna lace the gloves up I kind of
believe it and gay black men will [__]
people literally but I mean I appreciate
y'all for me honestly like I'm a giant
[__] you could take anything from me
that you want you can rob me in the
street you can rob me in my room good
with this
where is he going with this we see our
last [__] in this fake-ass world
getting discriminated against [__] we
right that this was not what I expected
at all so like you're a public figure
you can't really be involved in drama
he's literally got almost the same other
subscribers as me he's talking about me
like I'm like running for president yeah
that's why I let me do it let me be do
what though what is he planning on doing
that's what I'm worried about negative
rights for you am i as strong as you the
eyes the eyes unbelievable [__] my life
means nothing I'm like this possible
income you're not disposable don't talk
about yourself that way sky let me do it
let me fight this guy would literally
kill for me it's sort of worrying but
it's also confident because if any one
of us does so piss me off
I guess sky under you just the next
person to come at me you gotta get past
the Hitman general I'm saying like in my
obituary if you want to say something
like damn this [__] was a real ass
[__] for me see I would be like are
you write me with it I don't think I'm
quite worded the way you did to be
honest with you man but I'll say
something nice I got so much see that's
the thing you know you can fight for
yourself because you strong as hell but
if you fought for yourself then the
media would be like damn this buff [__]
just got people up and with me as big as
I am they'd be like wow obese gentleman
over here he is so [__] funny about
it we don't even have to make a decision
right now but just think about it my
friend just parked whoa look at his
friend his friend looks sick of his
[__] life that's the nicest video
anyone's ever sent me which begs the
question what kind of videos I get send
on a day-to-day basis after watching
that I can't help but feel let down by
the people of me like figure supposed to
care I was cuz he gives more of a [__]
about me than anyone who knows me I just
want to put the hope they run even
though literally no one's ever said
anything that nice perform sort of
upsetting that never mind
so back the Logan Paul Colin is finally
gonna get there he got my number off of
one a KS eyes team and I was like Logan
Paul wants to ring me oh I was [__]
shocked to be honest with you but sort
of Julius because I'm like alright house
cuz he's he's clever with the edits this
guy I'm thinking that what's gonna go
down yeah I better record this [__] just
in case everyone text me who knew me
when you have to record this you don't
know what he's capable of but to be fair
when he got in the foreword it was quite
a lunch actually now in the past when
Logan's done something wrong I've
slammed them and done it [__] publicly
and I think it's only fair that when he
does something right I'll give him the
same treatment and to me he did
something right yeah he manned up
supported me on the phone and apologized
and gave me a lot of respect and I
appreciate that and as someone who has
been affected by suicide the way spoke
about his regret over that video it
seemed very sincere and I know a lot of
people like they'll be skeptical now
Jordy you're only saying that now
because he's letting you comment it on
the fire or whatever look I think I'm a
pretty good reader of people and I'm not
saying the kids are saint by any means
I've seen a very different version of
him on the phone than what you say in
the videos now his audience are not me
I'm a grown-ass man and maybe this is
the version of Logan that people around
him say and if it is then you seem like
a pretty decent dude genuinely it left
me feeling more hopeful that if this guy
is gonna lead YouTube in the future that
we've got someone who can turn it around
he's a bright lad but is being very
immature and got swept away and craving
the content and the show and just
getting the success without really
thinking about what am I doing here and
I'm hopeful that years learning from his
mistakes and the way he approached me
impressed us so for something soon it's
squashed that's it it's over and done
with he wants me to commentate JJ wants
me to commentate I'm [__] all over it
I'm looking forward to this and just on
these two lads it both made a lot of
mistakes of the past and they're going
at each other right now when everyone's
criticized them and I just want to say
like you know how many people in their
early 20s who became that famous that
rich that quake
[__] up I'm not saying I would have
turned the same things that these two
lads have done but I'm sure would have
[__] up in my own way probably equally
as bad in some other way so these two
lads are drugging YouTube into the
mainstream without them nobody would be
[__] listening to us right now like I
love pewdiepie he's [__] Larry's but
not the only type mainstream listens to
him is when he said something wrong when
fortunately so because they're putting
on such a show we have to be heard and
that success that trickle-down effect
will be felt by all the youtubers all
YouTube fans and hopefully we'll finally
get some respect that we deserve and I'm
gonna do my bit to try and be the
commentator be the voice that gives this
some credibility as well and I hope I
don't let us down I'll do me best and
I'm just grateful that I'm going to be
involved in this because I live and
breathe YouTube and I love being a
commentator so it's gonna be a dream for
me to do this event I'm really looking
forward with no another dream of mine
was to have 1 million subscribers and in
the last week that happened when I
started YouTube the goal was always a
million subscribers but I realized along
the way that my style my no [__]
attitude wasn't gonna always get people
on site do you know I mean occasionally
I'm gonna piss a few people off but I've
stuck to my guns do you know I mean and
some of the content I like to make like
podcasts they're not gonna they're not
clickbait titles you know it's gonna be
harder I do it that way but you know I'm
gonna be making the content I want to
make and by telling stories which is
ultimately what I love to do and I've
done with the documentaries and the
podcasts I'll be happier than if I had
10 million subscribers making stuff I
don't like so I just sort of made me
peace with it that I might never do that
all of a sudden to work hard on me craft
all these years now when to try and
become a great speaker at a camera and a
good storyteller and a good interviewer
and what I really want to do is be able
to do it all do you know I mean I want
to be able to take you on a documentary
I wanted me to do a travel video I want
to do a vlog I want to do a podcast I
want to do it like interview everything
it's really important to me that I'm
good at what I do
more so than whatever the measurement
saw that other people are operating on
Gina I mean and it's so funny to end up
getting the million subscribers by avid
beef which is silly with a youtuber
I'm not going to complain it's happened
and I think I think I've earned it and
I'm really grateful to so many people
around me for helping me get there
because so many people have sort of
helped build this with me and and I'm
gonna thank them all a podcast coming up
which is the million subscriber podcast
that I'm sure that that will be
entertaining for you lot cuz I'm gonna
be [__] drunk but if you've already
just joined the channel and you haven't
seen the journey don't worry I've got
something for you because it's been one
hell of a ride raising message to nail
Ranger here you castle have been nothing
short of absolutely [__] [__] this
season what's going on everyone it's the
true draw debug again with the New
Castle so hunt and review on give a [__]
I just want to win a trophy man I want
to win the Premier League one day I want
an FA Cup win one I don't think they'll
ever be and after YouTube for me I think
I always do YouTube as long as you like
here supportin isn't one of watches if I
get opportunities to do other things as
well as YouTube or down the road maybe
podcasting
- the true Geordi podcast normally
divide them but you know with you guys
every podcasters to come out and watch
beginning to end I'm a huge fan how did
you do all this wasn't such a good
friend
yeah it was very difficult because I was
with him the deer before he did it and
everything seemed fine I'd gone from
extremely hurt - so angry with him and
it was just because I see his two boys
in I can do it how you want to do it
they put your [__] makeup on get
dressed meditates [__] put your
videos out laughs your world record dad
left you can be the best in the world at
deadlift in then why the [__] can't you
be the world's strongest man you know I
never had like a role model at school it
was local who I could achieve what they
had done this wasn't part of the plan I
was a deep-sea diver working offshore of
course never away and then there's Naomi
on and now I'm about the commenting on
the biggest event in youtube history
there was a week way as a ship on the
Fort Bragg North Carolina literally
[__] go nothin see some suits at my
type cost more than your house system I
either get like sponsorships and all of
that if you keep you in Downton keep
doing what you want to do companies will
cater to that you say the deal with
coral I see it so many zeroes but people
because I felt that way before and my
life has gotten so much better from when
I was in that place that because of you
love
[Music]
from the north of England he's known as
Judy for a very good reason
let's light that night one more time
we got started living how I wanted to
live in the heart was told that this is
how we're supposed to live this is what
you're supposed to do when I walked away
from diven I was on [__] good money
and I literally could have ended a saw
on my [__] ass and and there's been
weeks and months on with YouTube where
being on me [__] arse but the thing
is YouTube could all go tits up tomorrow
but the bottom line is that still rather
be where I am now than have stayed the
course like Frank Sinatra said dare it
my way